Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2022, I talked to psychologist Abigail Marsh about her research on psychopathy, why psychopathic traits are far more common than most of us realize, and why psychopaths in real life don't look like those in the movies. I hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. We'll be back with new episodes beginning August 26th. Most of us have heard the term psychopath and may have an image of what a psychopath looks like, whether that's Charles Manson or Ted Bundy or even the fictional Hannibal Lecter.
《心理学热线》目前正在休暑假，因此我们重播了过去一些最受喜爱的单集。在2022年，我采访了心理学家阿比盖尔·马什，探讨了她对精神病态的研究、为什么精神病态特质比我们大多数人意识到的要普遍得多，以及为什么现实生活中的精神病态者看起来并不像电影里那样。希望你喜欢这期来自档案库的节目。我们将在8月26日带着新节目回归。我们大多数人都听说过“精神病态者”这个词，并且脑海中可能会有一个关于他们外表的形象，无论是查尔斯·曼森、特德·邦迪，还是虚构的汉尼拔·莱克特。
The word itself, psychopath, brings to mind horror movies, serial killers, arson, and other mayhem. But psychopathy isn't just about terrible people who commit heinous crimes. Psychopathy is more common than most people realize. people with psychopathic traits show less empathy and remorse than other people. They may lie, cheat, and steal, but they may also be friendly, smart, and basically unremarkable. In other words, impossible to pick out of a crowd. Although severe psychopathy affects just about 1% of people, some research suggests that close to 30% of us have some level of psychopathic traits.
"精神病态者"这个词本身就会让人联想到恐怖电影、连环杀手、纵火和其他混乱。但精神病态并不只是关于犯下滔天罪行的可怕人物。精神病态比大多数人意识到的更为常见。具有精神病态特质的人表现出的同理心和悔恨感比其他人要少。他们可能会说谎、作弊和偷窃，但也可能表现得友好、聪明且基本上不引人注目。换句话说，在人群中根本无法分辨出来。尽管严重精神病态仅影响大约1%的人，但一些研究表明，我们当中近30%的人在某种程度上具有一定程度的精神病态特质。
And we may even know people who fall under this broad umbrella. So what do researchers know about the causes of psychopathy? How is psychopathy related to other mental health disorders? Are psychopaths born? Or are they made by their family life, by their environment? Are there effective treatments for it? Can children show psychopathic traits? And if so, how early?
我们甚至可能认识符合这一广泛定义的人。那么，研究人员对精神病态的成因了解多少？精神病态与其他心理健康障碍有什么关系？精神病态者是天生的吗？还是由他们的家庭生活或环境造成的？对此有有效的治疗方法吗？儿童会表现出精神病态特质吗？如果有，会有多早？
And if you recognize psychopathic traits and someone close to you, what should you do? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Abigail Marsh, a professor of psychology and neuroscience at Georgetown University. She studies psychopathy as well as its opposite, extreme altruism and pro-social emotions, such as empathy, compassion, and remorse.
如果你在身边的人身上识别出了精神病态特质，你应该怎么做？欢迎收听《心理学热线》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是乔治etown大学的心理学和神经科学教授阿比盖尔·马什博士。她研究精神病态以及它的对立面——极端利他主义和亲社会情感（如同理心、同情心和悔恨感）。
She studied both psychopaths and extreme altruists, such as extreme altruists, such as extreme altruism, is people who donate kidneys to strangers. And she's interested in exploring the emotional processes and the brain differences that can explain both of these extremes of human behavior. In addition to her many scientific publications, Dr. Marsh is author of the award-winning book The Fear Factor, How One Emotion Connects Altruists, Psychopaths, and Everyone in Between. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Marsh. Thank you so much for having me. I'm thrilled to be here. So let's start as we often do on this podcast with a definition. There are a lot of misconceptions about psychopathy and psychopaths. I mentioned some of them in my introduction, like the fact that people may think that all psychopaths are
她研究过精神病态者和极端利他主义者，比如极端利他主义者，比如极端利他主义，也就是把肾脏捐给陌生人的人。她有兴趣探索能够解释这两种极端人类行为的情绪过程和大脑差异。除了她的许多科学出版物外，马什博士还是获奖书籍《恐惧因素：一种情绪如何将利他主义者、精神病态者以及介于两者之间的所有人联系起来》的作者。感谢您加入我们，马什博士。非常感谢邀请我。我很高兴能来到这里。那么，让我们像在这个播客中经常做的那样，从一个定义开始。关于精神病态和精神病态者，有很多误解。我在导言中提到了一些，比如人们可能认为所有精神病态者都是
violent criminals. What are the traits that define psychopathy and how do they manifest themselves in people's behavior? The most important thing to remember about psychopathy is that it's a personality construct. It's based on a constellation of three kinds of personality traits, which include at the real core of the construct is callousness, meaning insensitivity to other people's suffering, truly not caring about other people's welfare. In addition to that, people who are psychopathic tend to have bold, sort of dominant, fearless personality styles, and they also tend to be relatively disinhibited. So they have trouble controlling their behavior, trouble managing impulses. And if you have all three of those personalities,
暴力罪犯。定义精神病态的特质是什么？它们又是如何在人们的行为中表现出来的？关于精神病态，最重要的一点是要记住它是一种人格结构。它基于三种人格特质的组合，其中该结构的核心是冷酷无情，这意味着对其他人的痛苦麻木不仁，真正不关心他人的福祉。除此之外，具有精神病态的人往往具有大胆、某种程度上占支配地位、无所畏惧的人格风格，而且他们也往往相对缺乏抑制力。因此，他们在控制行为和管理冲动方面存在困难。如果你同时具备这三种人格，
traits, we would say that you're psychopathic, especially if you have them to a really large degree. But they can manifest in all sorts of different ways behaviorally. Sometimes, more often in men than women, although not exclusively, they do manifest as aggression and criminal violence. And people who are psychopathic who do show those behaviors, obviously, we care about understanding them. We want to try to prevent those outcomes if we can. But most people who are psychopathic are not violent criminals. That's actually the exception. it's much more likely to manifest in all sorts of smaller antisocial behaviors in daily life, from being lying and manipulator to sort of being a bully and threatening people to get what
特质，我们会说你有精神病态倾向，特别是当你达到非常高的程度时。但它们在行为上可以表现为各种不同的方式。有时（男性比女性更常见，尽管并非全部）它们确实表现为攻击性和刑事暴力。对于表现出这些行为的精神病态者，显然我们关心去理解他们。如果可能的话，我们希望努力防止这些结果。但大多数具有精神病态的人并非暴力罪犯。这其实是个例外。它更有可能在日常生活中表现为各种较小的反社会行为，从撒谎和操纵到某种程度上成为霸凌者并威胁他人以达到你的目的，
you want, to maybe committing lower-level crimes related to theft or con artistry, that sort of thing. So psychopathy is not an official diagnosis in the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders, right? Exactly. This is one of the many confusing things about it. Yeah. Why is that? It's a great question. It's one that you'll, there are slightly different explanations depending on who you ask, because of course the diagnostic and statistical manual is the result of a lot of people working together and making decisions together. The basic idea is that, so psychopity is an old construct. It was first formalized, depending on who you ask, and the, maybe late 1800s or certainly no later than the early 1900s, maybe most famously by Herbie Cleckley, the great psychiatrist in his book, The Mask of Sanity, which is a fantastic book, if you're interested in psychopathy, I highly recommend it. And he was the first to come up with a list of traits that typify people with psychopathy. And a version of those traits made it into early versions of the DSM are often under other names, you know, something other than psychopathy.
再到可能犯下与盗窃或诈骗艺术有关的较低级别的罪行，诸如此类。因此，精神病态并不是《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中的官方诊断，对吗？完全正确。这是关于它的众多令人困惑的事情之一。是的。为什么会这样？这是一个很好的问题。根据你问的人，会有稍微不同的解释，因为《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》当然是许多人共同努力和共同做出决定的结果。基本的想法是，所以精神病态是一个古老的构念。它首次被正式化，取决于你问谁，可能在19世纪末期，或者肯定不晚于20世纪初，也许最著名的是由伟大的精神病学家赫比·克莱克利在他的书《理智的面具》中提出，这是一本极好的书，如果你对精神病态感兴趣，我强烈推荐它。他是第一个提出典型精神病态者特征列表的人。这些特征的一个版本进入了早期版本的DSM，通常使用其他名称，你知道的，除了精神病态之外的其他名称。
The most reason version of the DSM has a disorder in it called antisocial personality disorder, which is sometimes confused with psychopathy. And it's not, it overlaps with psychopathy, but it's not the same. It mostly indexes persistent criminal behavior, again. And it focuses much less on the personality features of the, patients than psychopathy does. Whereas psychopathy is really strictly about personality, antisocial personality disorder is mostly about behavior. And so you can have lots of people who have antisocial personality disorder would not qualify as being psychopathic, or at least not
DSM最新的版本中包含一种被称为反社会人格障碍的障碍，有时这与精神病态相混淆。但其实并非如此，它与精神病态有重叠，但并不完全相同。它主要还是指向持续的刑事犯罪行为。而且它对患者人格特征的关注远不如精神病态那样多。而精神病态则严格关于人格，反社会人格障碍则主要关于行为。因此，你会发现许多患有反社会人格障碍的人并不符合精神病态的标准，或者至少没有达到很高程度，反之亦然。事实上，当前DSM中最接近精神病态的是针对儿童的一种诊断，即伴有有限亲社会情感品行障碍。现在，如果一个孩子符合该诊断的标准，我们仍然不会称他们为精神病态者。事实上，我现在尽量避免使用“精神病态者”这个词，而是坚持使用以人为本的语言，就像我们对待许多其他障碍一样。但这当然不是该领域的普遍做法。无论如何，我们绝不会称一个儿童为精神病态者。而且我们通常甚至尽量避免称他们具有精神病态倾向。
highly so, and vice versa is also true. Actually, the closest thing to psychopathy in the current DSM is a diagnosis in children, which is conduct disorder with limited pro-social emotions. Now, If a child qualifies for that diagnosis, we still wouldn't call them a psychopath. And in fact, I try to avoid now using the term psychopath and sticking with person first language, as we do for lots of disorders. But that's not a universal practice in the field, certainly. And in any case, we would never call a child a psychopath ever. And we usually try to even avoid calling them psychopathic.
我们会说也许他们有患精神病态的风险，或者他们有精神病态特质。一个患有伴有限亲社会情感品行障碍的儿童表现出持续的反社会行为，包括攻击性、霸凌、威胁、撒谎、操纵、违法行为，以及所有在患有精神病态的儿童身上往往能看到的行为。此外，有限的亲社会情感指的是具有冷漠的人格，同理心或悔恨感有限，并且往往不表现出强烈的情感，特别是像恐惧、悲伤和爱这样的情感。因此，如果你有一个符合该诊断标准的儿童，他们发展为精神病态的风险非常高。
We say maybe they're at risk for psychopathy or they have psychopathic. traits. And a child who has a conduct disorder with limited prosocial emotions shows persistent antisocial behavior, including aggression, bullying, making threats, lying, manipulating, delinquency, all the things that you tend to see in children who have psychopathy. And in addition, limited pro-social emotions refers to having an uncaring personality with limited empathy or remorse and tending not to show strong emotions, in particular emotions like fear and sadness and love. And so if you have a child who qualifies for that diagnosis, they're at very high risk for developing psychopathy.
你对表现出这些特质的儿童做过不少研究。我知道对于有这种孩子的父母来说，这是极其、极其困难的。你如何帮助他们应对这些情况？有没有什么针对儿童的治疗方法或许可以把这种行为扼杀在摇篮里，然后你又如何与父母合作呢？当父母有具有这些特质的孩子时，这是一个非常棘手的问题。不幸的是，正如许多人所知，首先真正缺乏训练有素的儿童心理学家和精神病学家。
And you've done quite a bit of work with children who manifest these traits. And I know that it's highly, highly difficult for parents who have such children. How do you help them deal with this? Are there treatments for the children that maybe can nip this behavior? in the bud, and then how do you work with the parents? It's a really difficult problem when parents have children who have these traits. Unfortunately, as many people know, there's a real lack of trained child psychologist and psychiatrists to start with.
因此，患有任何严重心理障碍的儿童的父母已经很难找到能够提供良好治疗的人了。尤其缺乏的是那些受过培训且有经验治疗有严重外化行为障碍的儿童的专业人员。这就是品行障碍、对立违抗性障碍等。我往往怀疑这些并不是大多数人从事儿童心理学或精神病学想要治疗的障碍，你知道的。而且，对那些对待他人很糟糕的人产生同情心可能会非常困难。我的意思是，这是一种人类的自然倾向。但我认为记住这一点非常重要，你知道的，孩子们并没有选择
So parents of children with any severe psychological disorder already struggle to find somebody who can provide good treatment. There's a particular lack of people who are trained and experienced in treating children who have serious externalizing behavior disorders. So that's conduct disorder, oppositional defiant disorder, et cetera. I tend to suspect that those are not the kinds of disorders. Most people go into child psychology or psychiatry to treat, you know. And it is, it can be really hard to feel compassion for people who treat others badly. I mean, this is a natural human tendency. But I think it's so important to remember that, you know, children don't choose
拥有他们所表现出的心理症状和特质。就像我们不会因为自闭症儿童或焦虑症儿童表现出的症状而责怪他们一样，我认为把品行障碍或对立违抗性障碍归咎于儿童的症状是极不合适的，仅仅因为这些症状确实伤害了其他人，这与大多数人对心理障碍的精神心理画像不太吻合。我们认为精神病患者可能有紊乱的思想，或者有很多焦虑、痛苦和折磨。这算是一种典型形态。而品行障碍和精神病态恰恰不符合这种模式。患有这些疾病的儿童经常否认有
to have the psychological symptoms and traits that they do. And just as we wouldn't blame a child with autism or a child with anxiety for the symptoms that we show, I think it's wildly inappropriate to blame a child with conduct disorder or oppositional defined disorder for their symptoms, just because those symptoms do hurt other people, which doesn't quite fit most people's mental profile of what a psychological disorder is. We think of people who are mentally ill as having maybe disordered thoughts or having, having lots of anxiety and suffering and distress. That's kind of the prototype. And conduct disorder and psychopathy just don't fit that mold. The children with these conditions often deny there's
任何不对劲的地方，因为相当自恋是精神病态人格画像的重要部分。这也是它很难治疗的原因之一。当然，如果你认为自己没有任何问题，问题就在于其他人。你就不会非常乐意接受别人试图改变你身上某些事情。不幸的是，根据20世纪末发表的一些论文，精神病态获得了“不可治疗”的名声。但事实并非如此。它是一种人格障碍。而人格障碍出了名地难以治疗，但绝对并非不可能。
anything wrong with them because being fairly narcissistic is a big part of the personality profile of psychopathy. And that is also one of the reasons it's very hard to treat. Of course, if you don't think there's anything wrong with you, the problem is with everybody else. you're not going to be super receptive to people trying to change things about you. Unfortunately, psychopathy developed a reputation for being untreatable based on some papers that came out in the late 1900s. But that's not true. It's a personality disorder. And personality disorders are notoriously difficult to treat, but certainly not impossible.
特别是如果我们能够识别出有发展为精神病态风险的儿童，它是可以治疗的。但这确实需要时间和大量的努力。在某些情况下，还需要大量的资源，这很不幸。最有效的治疗方法往往是针对父母如何反应他们的孩子的各种培训组合。我谨慎地说出这一点，因为人们太容易假设，如果你是通过处理父母的行为来帮助治疗这种状况，那就是父母的行为导致了这种状况。
And especially if we can identify children who are at risk for developing psychopathy, it is treatable. But it does require time and a lot of effort. And in some cases, a lot of resources, which is unfortunate. The most effective treatments tend to be some combination of training aimed at how parents respond to their children. And I say this with caution because it's too easy for people to assume that if you are addressing parents' behavior to help treat the condition, that it's the parent's behavior that caused the condition.
我认为这是一个我想打破的巨大迷思。我们知道行为疗法，其中很多是由父母实施的，是治疗自闭症儿童非常有效的疗法。你必须使用非常特定的人际行为来帮助他们发展。但我们并不认为父母导致了自闭症，或者至少现在不这么认为了，对吧？我们过去曾那样认为。这过去曾是心理学界公认的智慧，即冷漠的母亲导致了她们孩子的自闭症。不幸的是，我们在精神病态方面仍然处于那种境地，许多人假设是
And I think that's a huge method I'd like to dispel. We know that behavioral therapy, a lot of it administered by parents, is a really effective treatment for children with autism. You have to use very specific kinds of interpersonal behaviors to help them develop. But we don't think that parents cause autism, or at least not anymore, right? We used to think that. This used to be just accepted wisdom in psychology, that refrigerator mothers cause their children's autism. Unfortunately, we're still in that place with psychopathy where a lot of people assume it's
父母的行为导致了它。因此，尽管这不是真的，但父母确实可以做一些事情来提供帮助，但这些并不是父母会自然而然想出来的行为。通常有几种不同的形式化治疗方法是有效的。其中大多数强调如何为做正确事情的孩子提供极其清晰、一致、积极的强化，并确保他们做错事情不会得到强化，对吧？不要陷入发脾气。不要向操纵妥协，因为如果你向这些行为妥协，你就会强化它们，并确保它们卷土重来。他们还强调不要依赖惩罚来改变孩子的行为。关于精神病态，真正困难的事情之一是它似乎植根于无所畏惧的气质。而惩罚发挥作用的方式正是通过恐惧系统。我的意思不是指，你知道的，必然是暴力惩罚。但任何时候，当你避免你认为会受到惩罚的行为时，那就是恐惧在说话。
parents' behavior that causes it. So even though that's not true, there are things that parents can do to help, but they're not the sort of behaviors that parents would naturally come up with on their own. Usually there's a number of different kinds of formalized therapeutic approaches that work. Most of them emphasize how to provide children with extremely clear, consistent, positive reinforcement for doing the right thing and ensuring that they're not reinforced for doing the wrong things, right? Don't get into the tantrums. Don't get into the tantrums. give into the manipulation because if you give into those behaviors, you reinforce them and you make sure that they come back. They also reinforce not relying on punishments to change children's behavior. One of the really difficult things about psychopathy is the fearless temperament that it seems to be rooted in. And that's how punishment works is through the fear system. And I don't mean, you know, violent punishment necessarily. But anytime you're, you avoid a behavior that you think will be punished, that's fear talking.
你会想：我不想让那件坏事发生，所以我不做这个我不应该做的事情。而那些具有精神病态的儿童，我合作过的许多人确实是无所畏惧的。他们说他们从来没有对任何事情感到害怕。他们不报告在受到威胁时身体有任何高自主唤醒的感觉。而且他们很难描述恐惧是什么感觉。因此，你无法通过惩罚来改变一个不感到恐惧的儿童的行为。顺便说一句，这对任何儿童都不是一个好的育儿策略。另一件事是，患有精神病态的儿童通常表现得对亲密情感非常抗拒
You're like, I don't want that bad thing to happen, so I won't do this thing I'm not supposed to do. And children who are psychopathic, many of the ones I've worked with truly are fearless. They say they have never felt afraid of anything. They don't report feeling any, you know, high autonomic arousal sensations in their body under threat. And they have difficulty describing what fear feels like. And so you can't punish a child into behavior. who doesn't feel fear. And P.S., that's not a good parenting strategy for any child. And the other thing is that children who are psychopathic often seem very resistant to affection
或者他们似乎无法从亲密情感中获得太多东西，原因我们目前还不是真正理解。因此，有时父母有时不会对外表表现出对这些孩子的亲密，既是因为他们对这些孩子感到沮丧，也是因为孩子似乎并不想要它。但有一些迹象表明，他们应该做完全相反的事情，这违反直觉，他们应该提供额外大量的社交积极线索、更多的亲密、更多的微笑、更多的积极身体接触，这比看起来自然的要多，甚至比孩子似乎想要的还要多。我们知道有一些证据表明，使用这类方法的父母，即使对
or they don't seem to get a lot out of affection, for reasons we don't really understand yet. And so sometimes parents will sometimes not be as outwardly affectionate towards these children, both because they're frustrated by them and both because the child doesn't seem to want it. But there's some of it that it to suggest that they should do exactly the opposite, which is counterintuitive and that they should be, provide extra big sort of social positive cues, more affection, more smiles, more positive physical touches than seem natural and that the child even seems to want. And we know there's some evidence that parents who use these types of approaches with even
风险极高的儿童，从长远来看也能看到良好的效果。但这很有挑战性。我不会介意。那么，是否有可能教导一个可能有这种特质的儿童（对成年人来说可能更难），教导一个有这些特质的儿童去感受恐惧、理解恐惧，并去感受到他们显然没有的悔恨感呢？这些都是非常重大的未解问题。精神病态领域真正的难题之一是，多年来没有投入足够的心理健康资源来试图理解或治疗它。它非常普遍。
very high-rich children can see good effects in the long run. But it's challenging. I won't mind. So is it possible then to teach a child that may be even harder with adults? but to teach a child who has these traits, to feel fear, to understand fear, and to feel remorse, which they apparently don't. These are really big open questions. One of the real problems with the field of psychopathy is that not enough mental health resources have been devoted to trying to understand or treat it over the years. It's very common.
品行障碍影响了多达7%的儿童（根据估计，在发育的某个阶段），对立违抗性障碍则更多。在发育过程中，有多达2%到3%的儿童具有高水平的有限社交情感。这些并不是罕见的疾病。精神病态至少和双相情感障碍、厌食症或我们认为并不那么罕见的其他一些疾病一样常见。然而，投入极少极少的资源来试图理解如何治疗它。
Conduct disorder affects, depending on the estimate, up to 7% of children at some point during development, social defiant disorder even more. And there are as many as two to three percent of children have high levels of limited social emotions during development. These are not rare conditions. Psychopathy is at least as common as bipolar disorder or anorexia or some other disorders that we think of as not that rare. And yet very, very few resources have been devoted to trying to understand how to treat it.
因此，有很多事情是我们不知道的。例如，从来没有专门开发出一种单一的药物来治疗外化行为障碍。因此，患有这些障碍的儿童接受了许多其他类型的药物治疗，这些药物是为了治疗其他事情而开发的。其中一些确实似乎有所帮助。例如，用于治疗多动症的兴奋剂药物确实对一些有精神病态风险的儿童有所帮助。
And so there's a lot of things we don't know. There's not one single pharmaceutical that's ever been developed specifically to treat externalizing behavior disorders, for example. And so children with these disorders get treated with a lot of other kinds of medications that were developed to treat other things. Some of them do seem to help. So, for example, stimulant medications used to treat ADHD do help some children who are at risk for psychopathy.
这不应该是首选治疗方法。你应该总是从父母管理培训类型的方法开始，但有时作为一种很好的辅助手段，它会增加行为治疗的有时效果。有时会使用情绪稳定剂，它们可能是有效的。甚至有时也会使用抗精神病药物，并且可能是有效的。尽管我认为在儿童长期使用这些药物是有风险的。它们真的会增强儿童体验恐惧等情感的能力吗？尽管我们认为它们是所谓的“负面情感”，但它们对于适应性社会发展和社会功能是极其重要的。
It shouldn't be the first line treatment. You should always start with the parent management training type of approaches, but it's sometimes as a nice adjuvant, it will sort of increase the effectiveness of the behavioral treatment. Sometimes mood stabilizers are used and they can be effective. And even antipsychotic medications are sometimes used and can be effective. Although I think it's risky to use these drugs for a long time in children. Do they actually increase the capacity of children to feel emotions like fear that, although we think of them as, quote, negative emotions, are incredibly important for adaptive social development and social functioning.
可能不会。说实话，制药公司似乎对开发能让儿童变得更恐惧的药物不那么热心，这并不令人意外。那并不是真的。没有人对此感到舒服，对吧？我能理解。而且再次强调，这太糟糕了。人们很容易忘记恐惧在适当的程度上是一种多么有用的情绪，对吧？
Probably not. And to be honest, it's not surprising that pharmaceutical companies don't seem that keen on developing medications that will make children more fearful. That's not really. Nobody feels comfortable with that, right? Which I get. And again, it's too bad. It's easy for people to forget what a useful emotion fear is in the right, you know,
显然，过度的恐惧是没有好处的。但某种低水平的恐惧是极其重要的，因为（这也是我大部分研究的中心），它不仅能帮助你对来自其他人的负面反馈做出反应，而且感受恐惧的能力还能帮助你对其他人感受到的恐惧产生共情。这是防止人们做出引起他人恐惧行为的关键社会机制之一。这也是精神病态中的一个问题，因为他们自己往往不能强烈地感受到恐惧。他们不理解别人的恐惧，而且他们字面意义上不理解为什么在别人身上引起恐惧是错误的。这是一个巨大的问题。话虽如此，通过我一直在谈论的这些行为类的父母管理技术，也许有可能在患有
to a degree, right? Obviously, excessive fear is no good. But some low level of fear is incredibly important because, and this is what a lot of my research centers around, not only does it help you respond to negative feedback from other people, but the capacity to feel fear helps you empathize with other people's fear. And that's one of these critical social mechanisms that prevents people from doing things that cause other people fear. And this is a problem in psychopathy because they don't often feel fear very strongly themselves. They don't understand it in other people, and they literally don't understand why it's wrong to cause it in other people. It's a huge problem. Now, that said, it may be possible to increase other positive social emotions in children with
精神病态的儿童中增加其他积极的社交情感，主要是通过让他们将其他人视为社交上有回报的。因为这是一件非常好的事情。如果你认为与人的互动以及与人进行积极的互动本身是有回报的，通常这就足以让你的行为、你的社交行为独自保持在正确的一侧。
psychopathy through these behavioral sort of parent management techniques I've been talking about mostly by causing them to view other people as socially rewarding. Because that's a really good thing. If you view interactions with people and having positive interactions with people is intrinsically rewarding, oftentimes that's enough to keep your behavior, your social behavior, on the right side of things all by itself.
问题在于，有精神病态风险的孩子会从事许多让其他人感到困扰的行为，从烦人到实际造成伤害。然后你会从人们那里得到负面反馈，最终陷入这些负面强化螺旋中，在那里你只是认为其他人根本不值得关心或好好对待。而这正是你想要避免的。如果你采取了正确的方法，你最终可能会得到一个孩子，虽然他可能在气质上相当无畏，也不是世界上最关心人的人，但可以完全发挥功能，过上非常好的生活，并拥有良好的友谊和关系。我们花一分钟来谈谈成因，因为
The problem is that kids at risk for psychopathy engage in a lot of behaviors that bother other people from being annoying to being actually harmful. And then you get negative feedback from people and you can end up in these negative reinforcement spirals where you just view other people as really not really worth caring about or treating well at all. And that's what you want to avoid. And if you, you know, the right approach is taken, you can end up with a child who's maybe temperamentally pretty fearless and not the most caring person in the world, but can be totally functional and lead a perfectly good life and have good friendships and relationships. Let's talk for a minute about causes because
我知道你做过一些研究，包括脑成像，发现在表现出这种障碍的儿童的大脑中存在一些有趣的差异。另一个问题是，这些事情是基因决定的吗？我们知道吗？理解精神病态的成因对于提出更有效的治疗方法显然非常重要。再次强调，精神病态研究界迫切需要的是来自心理健康组织的更多资源。你知道，资助机构需要认真对待精神病态，将其视为一种需要投入资源更好地理解它的精神疾病。话虽如此，我们已经取得了一些进展。有一段时间以来，针对有精神病态特质的儿童的脑成像研究一直指向一个相对一致的发现，即如果你观察有严重品行问题的大群孩子，比如攻击性、外化、违法行为，诸如此类。只有那些具有精神病态人格特质的儿童，也就是低同理心、较低
I know you've done some research, including brain imaging that found some interesting differences in the brains of children who are manifesting this disorder. And then the other question is, are these things genetic? Do we know? Understanding the causes of psychopathy is obviously really important to coming up with more effective treatments. And again, what the psychopathy research community desperately needs is more resources from mental health organizations. you know, funding organizations to take psychopathy seriously as a mental illness that needs, you know, resources poured into trying to understand it better. That said, we've made some progress. For a while now, brain imaging research in children who have psychopathic traits has been pointing to a relatively consistent finding, which is that if you look at large groups of kids who have serious conduct problems, so aggression, externalizing, delinquency, that sort of thing. only the children who have psychopathic personality traits, so the low empathy, lower
悔恨感和冷漠特质的儿童，表现出大脑中一个叫做杏仁核的结构活动减少。而在那些具有同样严重的攻击性、外化行为但没有精神病态特质的儿童中，你会看到相反的效果。他们实际上表现出杏仁核活动增加。这也是那些有趣的案例之一，脑成像告诉了我们一些对于理解这一现象以及识别适当治疗非常重要的东西，即患有品行障碍、攻击性等的不同儿童表现出完全不同的机制，这些机制似乎是
the morris and uncaring traits, show reduced activity in a structure called the Imigula. And you see the opposite effect in children who have equally serious, aggressive, externalizing behavior, but don't have the psychopathic traits. They actually show increased activity in amygdala. And this is one of those interesting cases where brain imaging has told us something really important to understanding the phenomenon and to, identifying appropriate treatments, um, that different kids with conduct disorder, aggression, et cetera, show completely different mechanisms that seem to be
他们反社会行为的基础。知道这一点真的很重要。因此，我们对杏仁核的了解是，首先它有很多功能。它是一个大脑中高度互联的结构。你有两个杏仁核，
underlying, underlying their, um, antisocial behaviors. And that's really important to know. And so what we know about the amygdala is it does a lot of things, first of all. It's a, it's a densely interconnected structure in the brain. Um, it's there, you have two amygdala, uh, one on each side and they're sort of deep under the cortex and they're evolutionarily ancient. Uh, one of the important things. things they do is regulate the body's fear responding. So they coordinate responses to threats. And people who have lost their amygdala is due to either genetic disorders or in some cases injuries do seem to have kind of muted fear responding as a result. So we think the amygdala is
两边各一个，它们位于皮层的深处，在进化上非常古老。它们所做的重要事情之一是调节身体的对恐惧的反应。因此，它们协调对威胁的反应。由于基因障碍或在某些情况下受伤而失去了杏仁核的人，作为结果似乎确实具有某种减弱的对恐惧的反应。所以我们认为杏仁核对于
important for fear. It also definitely plays an important role in sort of regulating social behavior, although exactly how it's doing that is less clear yet. And we think that because Because in children who are at risk for psychopathy, the amygdala is not developing correctly. It ends up being too small on average, especially earlier in development. And it's less active in response to the things that it should respond to. For example, the sight of somebody else who's afraid. That seems to be at the heart of the problems that we see in children with psychopathy. Now, it's not the only problem in their brains, but it's the one that has been the most consistently identified.
恐惧是很重要的。它肯定也在某种程度上调节社会行为中发挥着重要作用，尽管它到底是怎样发挥作用的目前还不太清楚。我们认为这是因为，在有精神病态风险的儿童中，杏仁核没有正确发育。平均而言，它最终会变得太小，尤其是在发育早期。而且它对应该做出反应的事情的反应活动较少。例如，看到其他人害怕的景象。这似乎是我们在精神病态儿童身上看到的问题的核心。现在，这并不是他们大脑中唯一的问题，但它是被最一致地识别出来的问题，
and the one that I think is likely to be central to their disorders. Is the disorder heritable? Well, every psychological phenomenon is at least partially heritable. So the same is certainly true for psychopathy as well. A giant meta-analysis that came out in, I think it was nature genetic several years ago, looked at the heritability of lots and lots of different outcomes, including psychological outcomes, and found that on average, psychological traits like personality traits, things like anxiety, psychological disorders, are an average 50% heritable, which means half of the variance can be accounted for by genetic factors.
而且我认为这很可能是他们障碍的核心。这种障碍具有遗传性吗？嗯，每一种心理现象都至少是部分具有遗传性的。所以精神病态也肯定如此。几年前发表在《自然遗传学》上的一项大型荟萃分析研究了大量不同结果的遗传性，包括心理结果，发现平均而言，像人格特性这样的心理特质、诸如焦虑之类的东西、心理障碍，平均有50%是遗传的，这意味着一半的变异可以用遗传因素来解释。
And the same seems to be true for psychopathy. So about half of the variance is accounted for by genetic factors. That does mean that if somebody else in a child's family shows signs of psychopathy, that child is at higher risk for developing psychopathic traits. But of course, that is a long way from saying that psychopathy is inborn or innate or hardwired. At every stage of development, genetic potential is interacting with environmental factors to drive outcomes. And so it's pretty clear that features of a child's environment will also shape the degree to which any sort of latent potential for psychopity gets expressed. That raises another question in my mind, which is, I think that some people confuse psychopathy and sociopathic. And I'm just wondering if you could explain how they're different and how they're similar.
精神病态似乎也是如此。因此，大约一半的变异是由遗传因素解释的。这确实意味着，如果一个孩子家庭中的其他人表现出精神病态的迹象，这个孩子发展为精神病态特质的风险就会更高。但当然，这距离说精神病态是天生的、先天的或硬编码的还有很长的距离。在发育的每个阶段，遗传潜力都在与环境因素相互作用以推动结果。因此很明显，儿童环境的特征也将塑造精神病态的任何潜在潜力得以表达的程度。这在我的脑海中引发了另一个问题，那就是，我认为有些人将精神病态和反社会人格障碍混淆了。我想知道你是否能解释一下它们有何不同以及有何相似之处。
Absolutely. Psychopathy, I will emphasize, is technically the more scientific term. So, for example, there are no scientific societies for the study of sociopathy. That's not a thing. There is one for the science of psychopathy. I'm a member, of course. There are no, as far as I'm aware, there are no sort of scientifically validated measures for assessing sociopathy.
绝对的。我要强调的是，精神病态从技术上讲是更科学的术语。例如，没有研究社会病态的科学学会。那是不存在的。有一个研究精神病态科学的学会。当然，我是个会员。据我所知，没有用于评估社会病态的科学验证测量方法。
There are not journal articles describing sociopathy. It's more of a sort of popular term for describing highly antisocial people. It has been used often on in the past to describe people with the diagnosis of antisocial personality disorder. And so I would say that sometimes that's what it's used to mean. Other times it's used to mean people whose antisocial behavior is mostly a result of social forces. So people who were not born at particularly high risk of becoming antisocial, but due to really terrible things that happen to them often in childhood, experiencing extreme neglect or trauma or abuse, developed antisocial behavior as a result.
没有描述社会病态的期刊文章。它更像是一个用来描述高度反社会人群的通俗术语。过去它曾断断续续地用来描述被诊断为反社会人格障碍的人。所以我想说，有时这就是它的意思。其他时候，它用来指代那些反社会行为主要是社会力量结果的人。因此，那些天生并没有特别高的成为反社会者风险的人，但由于他们在童年中经历的非常糟糕的事情，经历了极端的忽视、创伤或虐待，作为结果发展出了反社会行为。
Now, that's not even the normative consequence of experiencing abused trauma or neglect. You know, the typical outcome when you experience those terrible things in childhood is developing anxiety or depression or post-traumatic stress among other problems. But some children do develop very serious antisocial behavior as a result of those outcomes. And so, you know, again, it's not technically the scientific term, but many people, when they talk about sociopathy, that's what they need. There was no particular sort of innate risk factor. It was purely a social set of risk factors that cause their behavior, whereas psychopathy is almost always used to refer to people who are sort of have this innate set of risk factors that then becomes psychopathy as a result
现在，这甚至不是经历虐待、创伤或忽视的常规后果。你知道，当你在童年中经历那些可怕的事情时的典型结果是发展出焦虑、抑郁或创伤后应激障碍以及其他问题。但一些儿童确实由于这些结果而发展出了非常严重的反社会行为。所以，再次强调，从技术上讲这不是科学术语，但许多人在谈论社会病态时，指的就是这个。没有任何特定种类的先天风险因素，它完全是一套导致他们行为的社会风险因素，而精神病态几乎总是用来指那些拥有一套先天风险因素的人，这套风险因素随后在发育过程中发生的不同模式的作用下变成了精神病态。在我的导言中，我提到了一些经常被认为是精神病态者的臭名昭著的人，他们全都是男性。我只想知道，我们是否知道精神病态在男性或女性中更普遍，或者它只是根据你的性别表现不同？这是一个极好的问题。
of different patterns that happen during development. In my intro, I mentioned some notorious people who are often thought of as psychopaths, and they were all men. And I just want to know, do we know whether psychopathy is more prevalent among men or women, or does it just manifest differently depending on your sex? This is a wonderful question. And it's one that I think reasonable people could disagree on. We know that the scales that are most commonly used for assessing psychopathy now,
我认为理智的人可能会对此持不同意见。我们知道，现在最常用的评估精神病态的量表，
probably the most famous of which is the PCLR, the psychopathy checklist, which was developed by Bob Hare. It was developed in an all-male adult population of prisoners in British Columbia. And I think that scale is really good for assessing psychopathy. in adult male prisoners in North America. But I think reasonable people could differ as to how effective it is in assessing psychopathy in all its manifestations in other kinds of populations,
其中可能最著名的是由鲍勃·海尔开发的PCLR（精神病态检查量表）。它是在不列颠哥伦比亚省的成年男性囚犯群体中开发的。我认为这个量表对于评估
non-prison populations, children, and women. And there are other scales, I'll emphasize, that I really dislike the phrase gold standard when it comes to measuring any kind of construct. You know, any measurement is never the same thing as the construct. just one way to measure it. And some of the measures that I often use to assess psychopathy were developed in more general populations, and so maybe better at capturing psychopathy in, for example, women. So it's possible, I will say that we do see lower levels of psychopathy
北美成年男性囚犯的精神病态非常有效。但我认为理智的人可能会对它在评估其他类型人群、非监狱人群、儿童和女性的所有表现中的精神病态的有效性有不同的看法。我要强调还有其他量表，当测量任何类型的构念时，我真的很不喜欢“黄金标准”这个短语。你知道，任何测量都永远不等同于构念本身，它只是测量它的众多方法之一。我经常用来评估精神病态的一些测量方法是在更广泛的人群中开发的，因此可能更好地捕捉例如女性的精神病态。所以这是可能的，我要说的是，使用许多用于测量它的量表，我们在女性身上确实看到了较低水平的精神病态。这可能是因为这些量表是在更多男性的群体中开发的，因此它们不能很好地捕捉女性的精神病态，例如，它们可能强调身体攻击或不同形式的暴力犯罪，这些比女性更有可能是男性参与的。我们知道。因此，它们不能那么准确地捕捉精神病态在女性中的表现形式，而女性更有可能与社会攻击、某种情感霸凌、操纵以及类似的事情有关。
in women using a lot of the scales that are used to measure it. This could be because the scales were developed in more male populations, and so they don't capture psychopathy as well in women, you know, for example, they may emphasize physical aggression or different forms of violent crime that are much, much more likely to be engaged in by men than women. We know. And so they don't quite as accurately capture the ways that psychopathy manifests in women, which is much more likely to relate to social aggression, sort of emotional bullying, manipulation, and that sort of thing.
也有可能存在真正的性别差异。我相信这一点，部分原因是我们从世界各地国家进行的大型人格评估中了解到，男性和女性的人格存在平均差异，男性在一项名为负面情绪倾向的特质上略低，在尽责性特质上略低，在随和性特质上也较低。这些都是确实与精神病态相关的人格构念。
It's also possible that there are true gender differences. And I would believe that in part because we know from, you know, giant personality assessments that have been done in countries all over the world, that there are average differences in the personalities of men and women, with men tending to be a little lower in a trait called negative emotionality, a little lower in a trait conscientiousness, and lower in trait agreeableness. And these are all personality contracts that do relate to psychopathy.
毫不奇怪，患有精神病态的人不那么随和、不那么尽责，并且在某些形式的负面情绪上较低。鉴于此，我认为可以说，精神病态在极端情况下可能比女性更频繁地出现在男性身上。然而，我认为这也是真的，我们在女性身上低估了它，因为这些量表没有捕捉到它的一些表现方式。现在，如果你在日常生活中遇到你认为有这些特质的人，我的意思是，我在导言中问过，你知道，你能做什么？我的意思是，除了试图避开
People with psychopathy, not surprisingly, are less agreeable, less conscientious, and lower in some forms of negative emotion. And so given that, I think it's reasonable to say that probably psychopathy at the tails will show up more often in men than women. And yet, I think it's also true that we're undermeasuring it in women because the scales aren't picking up on some of the ways that it manifests. Now, if in your normal life, you encounter people who you think have some of these traits, I mean, I asked in the intro, you know, what can you do? I mean, other than just trying to avoid
这样的人之外，你有什么办法可以保护自己免受这类人的伤害吗？是的。我要说的第一件事是，精神病态的表现方式并不像人们想象的那样。我清晰地记得我第一次去采访一个患有精神病态的儿童的情景，当时我是国立精神卫生研究所（NIMH）的一名博士后。他是一个
people who are like this, is there anything that you can do to protect yourself from these kinds of people? Yes. The first thing I'll say is psychopathy does not present the way people think it does. I vividly remember the very first time I went to interview a child with psychopathy when I was a postdoc at the National Institute of Mental Health. And he was a He had pretty severe psychopathy. He was in a locked psychiatric ward at the NIMH. He was there for a long-term study that his parents had enrolled him in. And I had heard these horrible stories about his behavior and the backgrounds.
患有相当严重的精神病态。他在NIMH的一个锁着的精神病房里。他到那里是为了他父母让他参加的一个长期研究。我听过关于他的行为和背景的糟糕故事。
Uncontrollable violence, his parents, you know, would often take his brother to stay in a hotel for long periods of time. They were so worried about this boy trying to, you know, really seriously hurt or even kill his brother. where, you know, when he was being punished, he would do awful things like smear his own hoop on the walls. It was really, it was, it was bad stuff. And so the last thing I expected to see when I walked into his room, you know, and I knew how to like, you know, keep my, no, sharp objects in my pocket and make sure that I never let him get between me and the door.
无法控制的暴力，他的父母，你知道，经常带他的兄弟去酒店住很长时间。他们非常担心这个男孩会试图，你知道，真正严重伤害甚至杀死他的兄弟，其中，你知道，当他受到惩罚时，他会做一些可怕的事情，比如把自己的粪便涂在墙上。这真的很糟糕，真的很糟糕。所以当我走进他的房间时，我最没想到会看到的是，你知道，我知道如何像，你知道，把锋利的物件放在口袋里，并确保我从不让他介于我和门之间。
I mean, all the normal things that you do when you work with potentially violent populations. But I walk into his, his room at the NIH. And, you know, up from his, he was sitting on his bed and he pops up to shake my hand. It's just the cutest kid. I mean, he looked like he was out of a serial commercial. You know, like an adorable smile and just kind of sort of an aweshocks demeanor. Freckles on his nose. I mean, he just was so cute and sweet and friendly and charming.
我的意思是，所有你在与可能具有暴力倾向的人群合作时所做的常规事情。但我走进了他在美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）的房间。你知道，他从他的床边坐起来，然后突然跳起来跟我握手。他简直是个最可爱的孩子。我的意思是，他看起来就像是从一个麦片广告里走出来的一样。你知道的，带着可爱的微笑，还有一种有点羞涩的举止。鼻子上长着雀斑。我的意思是，他真的是那么可爱、温柔、友善又迷人。
You know, he seemed more mentally healthy than the average child. It was just astonishing. And he agreed that he had engaged in all these bad behaviors that had resulted in him being at the NIH. But there was always sort of an explanation for them. You know, oh, he just was having a really bad day that day. And looking back, maybe he shouldn't have done that. And that is what I learned in the most important lesson about psychopathy is that you can't
你知道，他看起来比普通儿童还要心理健康。这真是令人惊奇。而且他承认自己确实做过所有那些导致他来到美国国立卫生研究院的不良行为。但对这些行为总能给出某种解释。你知道，哦，他那天只是过得很糟糕。回想起来，也许他本不该那样做。这就是我学到的关于精神病态最重要的一课，那就是你无法
tell when somebody has it because they have a crazed look on their eye or they seem really gruff or there's, you know, weird eye contact. some people say, oh, yeah, there's a certain thing that people with psychopathy do. I've never seen it personally. And I think part of the reason is that I work with people who have not spent long time in prisons or institutions, which does things to your demeanor, obviously. People who are out in the community who have very high levels of psychopathy present as genuinely likable, charming, well-adjusted, friendly, often very helpful people in reality. I mean, this is how they managed to do all the terrible things that they do is because people don't see them coming.
仅凭某人眼神疯狂、显得粗鲁或者有奇怪的眼神接触就能看出他们是否有这种倾向。有些人说，哦，是的，患有精神病态的人有一种特定的行为方式。我个人从未见过。我认为部分原因是我合作过的人并没有在监狱或机构里度过很长时间，这显然会改变你的举止。那些在社会上生活、具有极高精神病态水平的人，实际上表现得非常讨人喜欢、迷人、适应能力强、友善，而且往往是非常乐于助人的人。我的意思是，这就是他们设法做出所有那些可怕事情的原因，因为人们根本防不胜防。
I mean, Ted Bundy was infamous for that. And I will say that, you know, many serial killers are not psychopathic. Some of them have very odd, you know, forms of psychosis or compulsions or other problems. Usually it's some sort of perfect storm of multiple problems. Ted Bundy was highly psychopathic in addition to being a serial killer. But you never would guess it. I've met psychology professors at the University of Washington who had, Ted Bundy as their students and introduced him to their wives and wrote letters of recommendation
我的意思是，泰德·邦迪在这方面是臭名昭著的。我要说的是，许多连环杀手其实并没有精神病态。他们中的一些人有非常奇怪的心理变态形式、强迫症或其他问题。通常这是多种问题交织在一起的完美风暴。泰德·邦迪除了是个连环杀手外，还具有高度的精神病态。但你绝对猜不到。我遇到过华盛顿大学的心理学教授，泰德·邦迪曾是他们的学生，他们把泰德介绍给自己的妻子，还为他写了推荐信，
for him and had absolutely no idea that he was simultaneously murdering women on the weekends when he wasn't in classes. You can't tell. If I lined up all the children with psychopathy that I've ever worked with over the years and all the healthy kids that I've worked with over the years and asked you to pick out who is who you'd never be able to tell. So this is the first part of making sure that you can protect yourself from psychopathy. is just not assuming that it will look like your stereotype of it.
却完全不知道他周末没去上课时同时在谋杀女性。你根本看不出来。如果我把你多年来合作过的所有患有精神病态的儿童和所有健康的儿童排成一队，让你挑出谁是谁，你永远也挑不出来。所以，确保自己免受精神病态侵害的第一步，就是不要假设它会符合你对它的刻板印象。
The most important thing you can keep track of is how people treat other people. It's very hard to detect in somebody you've just met. But if you get to know somebody for a little while, the things to look up for are, first of all, different people having extremely different impressions of them. You know, some people saying that this person is like a really horrible person, other people saying this person's the nicest person in the world. that kind of chameleon-like behavior is not always indicative of psychopity, but sometimes it is. The other thing you look for is a pattern of behavior that suggests this person does not really care about anybody but themselves, right? Do they ever actually do anything that sacrifices their own welfare to help anybody else, including, you know, people that they say are friends or that they love? do they really seem affected and truly moved when other people are suffering?
你能掌握的最重要的事是观察人们如何对待他人。在刚认识的人身上这很难察觉。但如果你稍微了解某人一段时间，需要注意的事项首先是：不同的人对他们有极端不同的印象。你知道，有些人说这个人是个非常糟糕的人，另一些人说这个人是世界上最好的人。这种变色龙般的行为并不总是精神病态的标志，但有时确实是。你要寻找的另一件事是某种行为模式，表明这个人其实根本不在乎除了自己之外的任何其他人，对吧？他们是否真的做过任何牺牲自己的福利去帮助别人的事，包括那些他们说是朋友或他们爱的人？当其他人遭受苦难时，他们真的看起来受到触动并真心难过吗？
Do they seem just a little too glib, just a little too able to kind of talk their way out of situations? Do they always seem to be kind of skirting just on the edge of acceptable behavior and not seem to think that maybe the rules apply to them as much as they do to other people? Those are the kinds of things you want to look for when you're just in daily life and think that somebody may have high levels of psychopathy. I should also mention that there are people who are fairly callous people who have most of the traits of psychopathy who are actually just fine people to know in your life. You know, I wouldn't necessarily let them, you know, propose, you know, an outing to go white river rafting or anything like that. You know, many people with psychopathy say they often get their friends into a lot of trouble.
他们是不是显得有点太油腔滑调了，有点太善于用言语摆脱困境了？他们是不是总是游走在可接受行为的边缘，似乎不认为规则对他们的约束和对其他人一样多？当你在日常生活中怀疑某人可能具有高水平的精神病态时，这些就是你想寻找的迹象。我还应该提到，有些人相当冷酷，拥有精神病态的大多数特征，但他们在你的生活中其实是完全好相处的人。你知道，我未必会让他们提议去白水漂流或类似的事情。你知道，许多具有精神病态的人说他们经常给朋友惹很多麻烦。
But the most important predictor of future behavior is past behavior. And so, you know, I know people who have psychopathy who have psychopathy who. who have learned that if they treat other people well, it works better for them too. And so oftentimes they can make good friends. You just have to always be aware of what you can and can't count on them for. Let's switch gears and talk about the happier side of your research, which is about empathy, compassion, and those extreme altruists like the people who donate kidneys to strangers. What's the connection between what seems on its face to be the opposite
但未来行为最重要的预测指标是过去的行为。所以，我知道一些患有精神病态的人，他们已经了解到，如果他们善待他人，这对他们自己也更有利。因此，他们往往能成为好朋友。你只需要始终清楚你可以指望他们什么，不能指望他们什么。让我们转换一下话题，谈谈你研究中更快乐的一面，也就是关于同理心、同情心，以及那些极端利他主义者，比如给陌生人捐肾的人。表面上看似乎是人类行为对立极端的两面，它们之间有什么联系呢？
extreme of human behavior? Yeah, so I've been incredibly fortunate in my research career to have been able to work not only with people who have psychopathy or at risk for psychopathy who to be honest, I really enjoy that research. I really feel for the parents of the kids
是的，在我的研究生涯中，我非常幸运，不仅能与患有精神病态或有精神病态风险的人合作——老实说，我真的很喜欢这项研究，我真的很同情那些患有精神病态的孩子的父母，
who have psychopathy, but I really enjoy the kids themselves. But I've also worked with people who were on the other end of what I call the caring continuum who are unusually caring and altruistic to the point that they will even give kidneys to strangers or rescue other people from fires or drowning. And the genesis of this research was the relatively recent understanding that psychopathy
但我真的很喜欢这些孩子本身。而且我也曾与处于我所谓的“关爱连续体”另一端的人合作过，他们异常富有同情心和利他主义，甚至愿意给陌生人捐肾，或者从火灾或溺水中救出其他人。这项研究的起源是相对近期才形成的认识，即精神病态
is not like a discrete group or tax on. It's not like we have psychopaths here and then the rest of the population over here. It's a continuum. You know, there are people who have mildly psychopathic traits. Some people have moderately or very severely psychopathic traits. So it's, you know, like a lot of things. It's sort of a normal district. Well, not a normal distribution, but certainly a distribution.
不像是一个离散的群体或分类。并不是说我们这里有一群精神病态者，而人口的其余部分在那一边。这是一个连续体。你知道，有些人有轻微的精神病态特征。有些人有中度或非常严重的精神病态特征。所以，你知道，就像很多事情一样。它有点像正态分布。好吧，不是正态分布，但肯定是一种分布。
And that discovery prompted me to wonder, well, if it's a distribution with super uncaring, uncompassioned people on one end, and most of us somewhere in the middle, what's on the other end? And if we can understand what it looks like to be sort of anti-psychopathic, that could help us learn a lot about the origins of compassion and care, which are the things that my research focuses on. And so after a bit of thinking, the population I landed on to see if they looked anti-psychopathic was people who donate kidneys to strangers. Because if there's any behavior that indicates more care about the welfare of other people, even total strangers, it's that when you're willing to give up an internal organ, a vital internal organ,
这一发现促使我思考，如果这是一个分布，一端是超级冷酷、缺乏同情心的人，而我们大多数人都在中间的某个地方，那么另一端是什么呢？如果我们能理解反精神病态是什么样的，那就能帮我们深入了解同情心和关爱的起源，这正是我的研究重点。经过一番思考，我锁定的用来观察他们是否看起来像“反精神病态者”的人群是：给陌生人捐肾的人。因为如果有什么行为能表明对他人福利（甚至是完全的陌生人）的更多关怀，那就是当你愿意放弃一个内部器官、一个至关重要的内部器官时，
at significant sometimes expense and inconvenience and sometimes serious pain to yourself, I don't know what it is. It's a really sort of a magnificent act of generosity. And so about 10 years ago, I started bringing altruistic kidney donors to my lab at Georgetown to conduct brain scanning research with them. And one of the first things we found about them is that they are indeed sort of anti-psychopaths. They have amygdalas, whereas people who are. who were psychopathic have amygdala's that tend to be too small and not active enough.
这往往伴随着重大的开销、不便，有时甚至是剧烈的身体痛苦，我不知道还有什么比这更厉害了。这真是一种壮丽的慷慨行为。因此，大约10年前，我开始把利他肾脏捐赠者请到我在乔治城大学的实验室，对他们进行脑部扫描研究。我们发现关于他们的第一件事就是，他们确实有点像“反精神病态者”。他们拥有杏仁核，而那些精神病态者
People who are very altruistic have amygdala that are larger than average and tend to be even more responsive to cues like the sight of other people in distress. So if you show them a picture of somebody who looks very afraid, they have a bigger than average in a migdala response to it. And that seems to support they're being better able at recognizing when other people are in distress. So if you show them fearful faces, they're better than average at recognizing them. And I think that means that they have the personalities that are unusually caring and responsive to other people's need and suffering.
的杏仁核往往太小且不够活跃。非常利他的人的杏仁核比平均水平更大，甚至对诸如看到别人痛苦之类的线索反应更强烈。因此，如果你给他们看一张看起来非常害怕的人的照片，他们对它的杏仁核反应会比平均水平更大。这似乎支持了他们能够更好地识别他人何时处于痛苦之中这一事实。所以，如果你给他们看恐惧的面孔，他们识别这些面孔的能力高于平均水平。我认为这意味着他们拥有异常关爱他人、对他人需求和苦难做出反应的个性。
And that makes them unusually motivated to help when other people are in need or are suffering. And you yourself are the benefactor of somebody who was apparently one of these altruists, right? I mean, can you tell that story? Because it's kind of amazing. I saw your TED talk about it. Oh, thank you. Yes. He certainly was a true altruist.
这使得他们在别人需要帮助或遭受痛苦时，具有异常强大的动力去提供帮助。而你本人就是某个显然是这些利他主义者之一的受益者，对吧？我的意思是，你能讲讲那个故事吗？因为这有点神奇。我看过你关于这事的TED演讲。哦，谢谢你。是的。他确实是一个真正的利他主义者。
Yeah, it happened when I was a teenager, and I certainly credited for the trajectory that my research career has taken. Yeah, I was driving home on Interstate 5, the Moore Treeway in Washington State, back to my hometown of Tacoma, also the hometown of Ted Bundy, and the hometown of the Green River Killer, and several other similar notorious. There's something in the water. Yeah, I know. There's no way it's an accident that I'm also injured in psychopathy. In any case, so I'm driving on an overpass back into town when a very small dog ran out in front of my car, which how it got there, I'll never know. And I swerved to avoid it, which I now know you shouldn't do, even though the impulse is always there. And the combination of hitting the dog and swerving to avoid it caused my car to spin out of control. It was fish tailing and then literally spinning in giant
是的，这发生在我十几岁的时候，我绝对把我的研究生涯所走的轨迹归功于它。是的，我正沿着5号州际公路（华盛顿州的莫尔高速公路）开车回家，回到我的家乡塔科马——这也是泰德·邦迪的家乡、绿河杀手以及其他几个类似臭名昭著的杀手的家乡。水里肯定有什么问题。是的，我知道。我研究精神病态绝不可能是个巧合。无论如何，当时我正开着车穿过一个立交桥回城，突然一只非常小的狗跑到了我的车前，它是怎么到那里的我永远也不会知道。为了避开它我猛打方向盘，虽然我知道现在不应该这样做，尽管本能总是促使人这样做。
circles across the freeway until finally it came to arrest in the fast lane of the freeway just over the crest of this overpass so that the oncoming cars couldn't see me until they were almost on top of me. And the engine died. And I was 100% sure that I was also going to die because I had a phone, couldn't get the car to turn back on. There was no shoulder for me to escape to. I literally, you know, I kept, I just remember trying to turn the car back on and being unable to do so. And so I don't know how long I sat there. I mean, time does funny things when you think you're about to die.
撞到狗和猛打方向盘避让的组合，导致我的车失控打转。车子先是尾部甩动，然后简直是在高速公路上打着巨大的圆圈旋转，最后停在了高速公路的快车道上，刚好停在这个立交桥的坡顶，以至于迎面驶来的车子直到开到我跟前才看到我。引擎熄火了。而且我百分之百确认为自己也会死，因为我带着手机，却无法让车重新启动。没有我可以逃往的路肩。我字面意义上，你知道，我一直在，我只记得试着重新启动汽车却无能为力。所以我不知道我在那儿坐了多久。我的意思是，当你觉得自己快死的时候，时间会变得很奇妙。
But what ended up happening was as I was sitting there, you know, waiting for the end, I hear a rap on the passenger side door, which was the side next to the shoulder. and turned to see a man standing there who I later figured out must have pulled his car over on the opposite side of the freeway within second of having seen my stranded car and then run across the freeway to reach me again in the middle of the night at the dark with cars and trucks flying past and to make a long story short he he got in my car and got it back up and running again which required putting it back in park and then got us back to safety. on the other side of the freeway and then disappeared.
但最终发生的是，当我坐在那里等待终结时，我听到副驾驶侧的车门被敲响了——那是靠路肩的那一侧。转过头看到一个男子站在那里，我后来琢磨出他肯定是在看到我抛锚的车几秒钟之内，就把车停在了高速公路的对面，然后又在黑夜里、在飞驰的汽车和卡车中间跑过高速公路来找我。长话短说，他上了我的车并把它重新发动起来了，这需要先把它挂回停车挡，然后把我们带回到高速公路对面的安全地带，接着就消失了。
He's like, are you going to be okay? Do you need me to follow you before you get home just to make sure you get home okay? And I said, no, no, I'll be okay. And he said, okay, well, then you take care of yourself. And off he went into the night. I don't know his name. I don't know anything about him. But I know that he was truly heroic.
他就像是问：“你没事吧？在你回家之前需要我跟着你，确保你安全到家吗？”我说：“不，不，我没事的。”他说：“好吧，那你保重。”然后他就消失在夜色中了。我不知道他的名字。我对一无所知。但我知道他真的非常英勇。
Yeah, yeah. It's quite an amazing story. Last question. I mean, I like to ask this a lot of researchers. What are the big questions that are fascinating you now? What are you working on? And in your mind, sort of the most important questions that we could still answer. Oh, there are so many.
对，对。这真是个神奇的故事。最后一个问题。我的意思是，我喜欢经常问研究人员这个问题：现在有哪些重大问题让你着迷？你在研究什么？在你看来，还有哪些我们仍能解答的最重要的问题？哦，有太多了。
I mean, it's one of the reasons I absolutely love being a psychology researcher and a neuroscience researcher is because these are relatively young fields and there are so many things we still have to know. And plus, I mean, what's more interesting than trying to understand human psychology and behavior? I think the most interesting question, and certainly the one that I'm in the way, the middle of pursuing is what is it that allows somebody to truly care about somebody else? I mean, you know, when you really boil it down, it's love, which I know is a little bit of a fluffy term and sometimes researchers try to avoid it. But, you know, the scientific definition of love is to care about somebody else's welfare for its own sake, not because of how it affects
我的意思是，这也是我绝对热爱做心理学研究员和神经科学研究员的原因之一，因为这些是相对年轻的领域，还有太多事情需要我们去了解。而且，再说了，除了试图理解人类心理和行为，还有什么更有趣的事呢？我认为最有趣的问题，也绝对是我正在着力探究的问题，是什么让人能够真正关心另一个人？我的意思是，你知道，当你真正归结到本质时，就是爱。我知道这有点像个虚浮的词，有时研究人员会尽量避开它。但是，你知道，爱的科学定义是为了对方本身的福祉去关心他，而不是为了它如何影响
you. And, you know, from having worked with altruists for 10 years now, I genuinely believe that it's possible and act common to genuinely care about the welfare of other people because they're intrinsically valuable to you. And how does the brain enable that? How do we have this capacity to genuinely care about other people? There must be some pathway in the brain that enables it, probably built on the pathways that originally evolved to support parenting, which is, of course, the original form of love is the love that parents have for their offspring. we think that in general, most forms of care-based altruism emerge out of the capacities for parental care.
你。而且，你知道，从与利他主义者合作了10年之后，我真的相信这是可能的，并且真心关心他人的福祉是常见的事，因为他们在你看来具有内在价值。大脑是如何实现这一点的？我们怎么会有这种能力去真正关心他人？大脑中一定有某种通路使之成为可能，它很可能是建立在最初进化来支持育儿的通路之上的，育儿当然是最初形式的爱——也就是父母对后代的爱。我们认为，总体而言，大多数基于关爱的利他主义都是从父母关爱的能力中演化而来的。
And so I would love to try to figure out how it is that the brain enables that capacity to emerge. I think it's, I mean, it's the most beautiful form of alchemy I can imagine. I'd love to figure out the answer. Well, thank you so much for joining me today, Dr. Marsh. This has been really interesting. I appreciate you're taking the time to explain your work to the world. It's been a pleasure.
因此我很乐意去弄清楚大脑是如何让这种能力得以展现的。我认为，这是我能想象到的最美丽的炼金术。我很想找出答案。好的，非常感谢你今天加入我们，玛氏博士。这真的很有趣。我很感激你花时间向全世界解释你的研究。这真是个荣幸。
Thank you so much for inviting me here. You can learn more about Dr. Marsh's work and other research on psychopathy in the March issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Go to our show notes for the link at speakingof psychology.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology there or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you listen to us on Apple, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiant. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢邀请我来。你可以在美国心理协会（APA）杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）3月号上了解更多关于玛氏博士的工作以及关于精神病态的其他研究。请访问我们的节目shownotes获取链接：speakingofpsychology.org。你也可以在那里或者在Apple、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学观察》以前的节目。如果你在Apple上听我们的节目，请留下一条评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以给我们发电子邮件：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学观察》由莉·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·康迪安特（Chris Condiant）。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。